meet the BMW 503 Cabriolet a car that
wowed car lovers it was the first German
car with an electric soft-top as
standard equipment its chassis was
entirely an aluminium it was the first
mass-produced car with a light alloy v8
engine and the sound was music to the
ear in 1956 BMW brought out the
company's most expensive model up till
then the 503 in the coop a and
convertible versions each sold for
twenty nine thousand five hundred marks
the price of a single-family home
Michelle push-off has owned his 503
Cabriolet for many years now and he
still thrilled by it
miss Miyamoto he invites us to imagine
it's 1956 just 11 years after the end of
World War two suddenly there's the first
car with a v8 engine and 150 horsepower
and it can go 190 kilometers an hour
that stacked up to the mercedes 300sl
with its gullwing doors which was a
gigantic car there really wasn't much
else like it in Germany at the time for
him the 503 still chops it all as a
weekly any shall Wayne ain't who by
outdoor them at this will beat anybody
the 503 cabriolet was a luxury car for
factory owners and film stars wealthy
industrialists like count faber castell
and rudolf al ghost burtka drove them in
the 1950s the elegant two-door model
took home gold medals from car shows in
can roam Lisbon and Vienna
absolutely Michele push off wax is
enthusiastic about the car's power
comfort and size the technology is
simple nicer than in modern cars the 503
holds four people comfortably making it
great for holidays and that's without
sacrificing sportiness the only thing to
slow him down is when there's traffic on
the road them with any forgive the
aluminium chassis was built by the
chassis specialist company Bauer in
stood guard the design didn't follow any
trends from abroad BMW came up with it
on its own the 503 marked a turning
point in BMW design a shift from pre-war
tastes to a leaner and more modern look
the understated pontoon shape did
without flashy effects and followed the
ideal proportions of a Gran Turismo car
a long hood and a short rear end
in its technology the 503 was based on
the big BMW sedans the 501 and 502 the
frame engine transmission and axles were
almost identical the interior is
impressive too with its clean beauty and
1950s aesthetics three round gauges
inlaid in a metal dashboard and a few
ivory colored buttons in 1956 this was
the state-of-the-art luxury
but the 503 came at a difficult time for
BWW few people in post-war Germany could
afford such exclusive cars BMW produced
only 139 of the convertible version over
the course of five years by the late
1950s BMW was on the verge of bankruptcy
the company rescued itself with small
cars like the Zetas and the BMW 700 but
of course they didn't have the luxury or
the power of a 503 the engine the
world's first cast aluminium v8 was a
masterpiece of German engineering two
carburetors fedot fuel later versions
had outputs of 119 kilowatts at the time
even Mercedes was offering only six
cylinder engines
today a 503 convertible in good shape
will set you back a quarter of a million
euros when it comes to vintage cars
BMW's 503 is a crown jewel